I'm mark Holmes and I'm a fashion  stylist I think I lay in New York  definitely have two different  sensibilities about themselves  la tends to be a lot more loose a lot  more casual than New York is a little  bit more particular about how things are  put together for me this is very much a  marriage of two worlds recognizing la  streetwear culture with the sweatpants  and the casual nature also with the LA  obsession with Footwear and sneakers but  then brought it back into New York  territory with the must-have essential  for New York which is the leather bomber  I'm very particular about my sunglasses  and if I'm gonna be in LA it's a  must-have as individuals all these  elements are very classic in their  silhouette and really when you're mixing  classic silhouettes together you really  can't go wrong just like The Macallan  double-cast combining both from the two  sides of the world to create a beautiful  whisky